[Musique]
bienvenue sur TV 78 toute cette semaine
retour sur les meilleurs moments du 7 8
c'est votre émission qui vous relais
l'actualité vous donne des infos
pratiques et vous propose également des
idées de sortie à faire sur le
territoire des Yvelines on continue ce
soir avec la fin du mois d'octobre c'est
un moment propice pour la cueillette des
champignons c'est aussi à l'automne que
l'agglomération de 50 ans en Yvelines a
poursuivi le déploiement de startsky
c'est bornes de recharge pour véhicules
électriques mais on commence tout de
suite avec le projet d'art convergence
elle l'association a fait monter sur les
planches des personnes en situation de
handicap psychique et mental le best of
du 7 8 c'est tout de suite
[Musique]
votre compagnie a travaillé avec
l'association Art convergence et il y a
des bénéficiaires qui jouent dans cette
création l'association Art convergence
qui accompagne des personnes atteintes
de maladies psychiques et donc le
festivalimago aussi qu'est-ce que c'est
le festival imago c'est la quatrième
édition c'est jusqu'au 20 décembre
c'est un énorme festival qui recouvre
toute l'Île-de-France et un peu au-delà
qui réunit de nombreux théâtres mais
aussi des médiathèques il y a le musée
du quai Branly qui est partenaire de
cette opération il y a eu la conférence
de presse de présentation donc c'est
assez fascinant et c'est vrai que autour
de l'architecture en fait je crois qu'il
y a une vraie mobilisation du public ça
c'est assez intéressant surtout dans nos
banlieues dans nos vies de nouvelles et
du coup j'avais pensé à l'association et
art et convergence avec qui j'avais
proposé de de monter un projet autour de
l'architecture avec les résidents de
l'hôpital de plaisir mais alentours
aussi parce que ça regroupe
Saint-Germain-en-Laye ça regroupe
vraiment plusieurs structures et donc
l'idée c'était de faire plusieurs
ateliers les maquettes donc on accueille
une exposition de maquettes dans le hall
du théâtre mais aussi un mini spectacle
une création avec un texte original
autour de l'architecture qui est presque
une sorte de préalable d'éclaircissement
à ce qui va se produire sur scène
pendant le spectacle vous avez commencé
à pitcher un petit peu la pièce tout à
l'heure on parle de forcément
d'architecture et du lien aussi de Le
Corbusier avec un jeune architecte qui
va aider exactement voilà c'est
l'histoire d'un jeune garçon de 12 ans
qui qui va avoir grâce à Le Corbusier un
destinée nouvelle qui va repartir un peu
sur un bon chemin il va devenir
architecte lui-même là au moment de la
pièce on le prend à 30 ans il est déjà
architecte au cabinet Le Corbusier et il
apprend la mort de Le Corbusier donc il
retourne à quatre Martins et à partir de
là il décide de suivre le cercueil les
étapes du cercueil donc en flashback il
va revoir toute sa vie tout ce qui s'est
passé les étapes importantes les moments
les plus truculents parce que dans la
mémoire généralement sélectionne
toujours le meilleur finalement et bien
cette mémoire on va la voir sur le
plateau et puis au théâtre on fait
revivre donc on va voir le corps que
j'ai lui-même sur le plateau on va voir
aussi tous les personnages de cette
époque c'est-à-dire que on va couvrir
quand même l'étranglorieuses on a on
couvre à peu près 50 ans de la vie de
cet homme et c'était assez intéressant
parce qu'on voit aussi au travers de sa
vie ce qui s'est passé dans cette époque
là mais d'une manière assez humoristique
lotrice Louise doutrelie a fait un
travail scénaristique assez
époustouflant en une heure 10 vraiment
on passe 30 ans et on voit pas on voit
pas le temps passer
en coulisse Louise Doutreligne qui est
venu avec vous on va regarder tout de
suite un extrait de la bande-annonce de
cette pièce ok
j'ai un château de 3 mètres 66 par 3
mètres 66 un château où séjourne
l'architecte le plus mal logé de la côte
les échanges entre lui et moi n'était
pas ceux d'un grand maître à un élève
non qui me parlait et qui faisait rêver
le gosse que j'étais il m'a donné des
conseils c'est tout nouveau 50 ans en
Yvelines va déployer de nouvelles bandes
de recharge pour les voitures
électriques oui baptisé Starsky il
s'agit de 50 nouveaux points de recharge
public qui seront proposés aux
utilisateurs les bornes déjà présentes à
Maurepas Coignières et Villepreux vont
être adaptés et modernisés vous aurez la
possibilité de brancher tous les types
de prise en acier ou DC l'objectif de
l'agglomération 200 bornes d'ici la fin
de l'année 2022 plus de renseignements à
venir sur le site sky.fr
la référence on a vu la couleur de la
voiture et parce que je suis grande
série bien sûr des années 80 des années
80 années 70 années 80 plutôt je parle
sur le contrôle de Florence Cardin merci
merci Mathilde pour ses actualités et je
vous garde encore quelques minutes
Mathilde puisqu' avec vous on va parler
de la maison Calypso c'est un équipement
qui a ouvert en janvier dernier à
plaisir tout à fait Grégory on en
parlait tout à l'heure cette maison donc
a pour but de lutter contre les
violences faites aux femmes au total ce
sont une douzaine de professionnels qui
les accueillent chaque semaine et le
site
une nouvelle maison va bientôt voir le
jour on regarde le reportage de Michael
el Minero et de Mélanie poquet
un nouveau site à quelques mètres
seulement pour continuer à accompagner
les femmes victimes de violence
l'extension de la maison Calypso devrait
voir le jour d'ici 2024 depuis son
ouverture en janvier 2022 le premier
établissement accueilli 187 femmes le
plus grand succès pour
Calypso ce sera quand elle pourra fermer
quand on aura plus besoin de nous voilà
alors bon le monde est monde et on s'est
malheureusement que ce besoin
va perdurer dans le temps on a cinq six
pièces on voit bien que les besoins sont
plus importants que ça puisque le
parcours d'une femme peut durer un an et
demi c'est pas on la voit une fois et
puis ça s'arrête là non elle a besoin de
venir de revenir de cheminer à besoin de
participer à des ateliers de
reconstruction de soi et ça prend ça
prend du temps
inspiré de la Maison des Femmes de
Seine-Saint-Denis Calypso regroupe une
douzaine de praticiens sage-femme
conseiller conjugale psychologue un
développement qui a attiré l'oeil de la
délégation droit des femmes de
l'Assemblée nationale est-ce que ça peut
être intéressant pour les oiseaux
les marques
des balades pour les curieux de nature
Solène Boivin organise des promenades
intitulées les grands curieux dans la
haute vallées de Chevreuse alors
rencontre du patrimoine de la faune et
de la flore les promeneurs avaient
rendez-vous à rezeux pour suivre la
naturaliste venue éveiller leur
curiosité
la commune a mis en place à différents
petits jardins pour protéger la
biodiversité donc c'est vrai que moi je
vais parler de toutes ces actions qui
comme l'arrêt de l'utilisation des
pesticides qui est très importante pour
pour sauvegarder tous ces milieux qui
sont riches et qui accueillent vraiment
beaucoup d'espèces vivantes une balade
entre nature et patrimoine sur les
traces de Robert Doisneau l'artiste
célèbre pour ses photographies
d'après-guerre a immortaliser des
instants de vie à rezeux en s'éloignant
du coeur de la ville l'environnement se
fait plus sauvage l'occasion d'apprendre
les secrets d'un arbuste communément
appelé bonnet d'évêque
on a vraiment des fruits qui vont
s'ouvrir qui vont être rose avec du
orange aussi donc des fruits très très
qui vont perdurer l'hiver qui sont pas
comestibles mais par contre c'est un
arbuste avec lequel on peut faire du
fusain d'Europe très facilement la
nature
dernier vous êtes allé cueillir des
champignons en forêt
oui je suis allée j'ai eu l'opportunité
d'aller cueillir des champignons samedi
matin et c'était tout aussi chouette de
faire ce sujet avec des mycologues
experts c'était très intéressant il y
avait des champignons vénéneux oui oui
on en a vu des mortels il faut vraiment
faire attention et
c'est important de le rappeler parce que
en fait finalement il y a plus de
champignons mortels et toxiques que de
champignons comestibles
c'est le nom de l'acteur hypocrites grec
spécialiste de la cueillette des
champignons j'ai fait ça pendant des
années ça me manque terriblement ah oui
bah vous avez l'opportunité de faire des
sorties cueillette de champignons avec
ces mycologues
[Musique]
focus à présent dans ce best-of sur un
sujet qui a animé l'actualité celui de
la cyber sécurité on ouvrira également
les portes d'une nouvelle école
d'agriculture à Saint-Quentin en
Yvelines mais d'abord on va faire la
connaissance d'un étonnant présentateur
météo
[Musique]
avec nous aussi Nicolas dandry bonsoir
désolé
vous êtes dans le fauteuil mais avec
vous on va quand même parler d'un truc
passionnant de technologie ouais des
technologies de 5g parce que durant les
championnats du monde de cyclisme sur
piste qui ont eu lieu ce week-end à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines d'ailleurs il
y a le paracyclisme qui commence et on
va en parler je crois et bien pendant
ces championnats du monde et bien ils
ont testé Nokia avec ses partenaires à
tester l'enceinte sportive connectée
c'est à dire que le vélodrome national
était connecté à la 5G et vous allez
voir ça permet beaucoup de choses
beaucoup de choses vous allez nous
raconter ça dans dans quelques instants
mais d'abord ça c'est une grande
première pour moi je suis très je suis
ravi de faire ça je vais me déguiser en
Miss Météo c'est-à-dire c'est très très
sexy de dire miss météo en Monsieur
Météo pour vous donner la météo de
demain vous voulez savoir quel temps il
va faire beau vous allez voir il fait
beau il fait beau dès le matin alors il
y a des températures voyez entre 15 et
degrés le matin c'est enfin c'est pas
mal c'est un peu nuage le matin
ça va s'améliorer tout au long de la
journée et l'après-midi on est dans les
20 degrés et puis du soleil à peu près
partout dans les Yvelines donc c'est
bien peut-être ou sur l'île de loisirs
50 ans
mais du soleil vous n'êtes pas grand
mais je vous dis il y a des gens qui
travaillent alors une question
importante c'est la cybersécurité
justement ce matin il y a eu l'ouverture
d'horizon cyber le rendez-vous
francilien sur la cybersécurité le but
vulgariser et montrer l'état de la
connaissance sur la cybersécurité pour
Jean-Michel fourgouse président de
l'agglomération de 50 ans en Yvelines
c'est aussi l'occasion pour les
entreprises de se rencontrer pour
participer à la meilleure sécurisation
de notre territoire il est question que
Saint-Quentin soit aussi dans les faire
de lance bien sûr de l'accompagnement de
nos entreprises de nos chercheurs
bien sûr pour protéger on a 17000
entreprises on est là aussi pour les
protéger avec nos moyens bien sûr et
avec nous toutes les entreprises
spécialisées qu'on a la chance d'avoir
sur 50 ans donc évidemment ce thème est
central et les Français doivent
comprendre que en termes de souveraineté
s'ils veulent garder une souveraineté il
faut que la France et une force de
défense en cybersécurité opérationnel au
meilleur niveau mondial
organisé par le hub cyber and sécurité
de system systématique l'événement
regroupé une centaine de personnes
qu'est-ce que c'est cette procédure de
49.3
avant chaque outil qu'on utilise il faut
un budget pour la France en l'année 2023
aujourd'hui nous devons consolider ou
mettre en ensemble deux priorités qui
ont été mises en avant par le
gouvernement et par notre majorité
depuis plusieurs semaines un la
protection des Français de le
rétablissement de finances publiques qui
est aussi en fait finalement une forme
de protection parce que on veut qui est
le moins d'être possible qui pèse sur
les générations futures et on veut
reconstituer notre trésorerie et si je
puis dire public pour faire face à des
chocs futurs qui pourraient être venir
l'idée que de ce de ce projet de loi de
finances 2023 c'est de garantir un
budget qui soit solide pour nous donner
les moyens financiers de répondre à ces
deux objectifs tant pour les ménages
avec notamment le bouclier tarifaire qui
va protéger de l'ensemble des ménages en
France mais c'est aussi protégé nos
entreprises notamment nos plus petites
entreprises et bien sûr tout le travail
qu'on fait aujourd'hui pour limiter le
choc sur les collectivités locales dans
le cas de cette crise énergétique
Nicolas dandry
émerveiller parce que les technologies
chinoises effectivement 56
particulièrement
disons on va élargir 50 ans ça va
jusqu'au plateau de Saclay puisque Nokia
c'est plus largement installé aussi sur
le plateau et on va prendre on va
revenir sur les Championnats du monde de
cyclisme sur piste durant 5 jours la
compétition de compétition et bah le
vélo de drone national s'est transformé
en enceinte sportive connectée c'est
dans le cadre du projet de Stadium Lab
c'est un projet donc emoniait par Nokia
Nokia vous savez c'est une
multinationale spécialisée dans les
télécommunications et notamment dans le
déploiement du réseau en 5G
finlandais finlandais et donc l'objectif
de notre Nokia et ses partenaires et
bien c'est d'améliorer l'expérience des
spectateurs dans les stades mais aussi
des téléspectateurs devant leur
télévision et à ce propos on écoute
Stéphane Holbert le directeur des
partenariats Europe chez nous explique
comment fonctionne tout cela d'accord on
déploie un réseau 5G privé donc c'est
c'est un serveur qui correspond à réseau
mobile ou un opérateur vers des millions
d'abonnés et ici on gère quelques
milliers d'abonnés comme vous pouvez le
voir sur sur la salle technique on
déploie ensuite des Smalls des petites
cellules on en a trois sur le filtre
dans les ondes mini Messi qui permettent
d'accéder à des très très haut débit
pour de la télé à 4K 8k mais également
des latence est faible pour pouvoir
piloter en temps réel ces images et
avoir cette passion et cette immersion
totale alors là on vient de voir toutes
les technologies qui permettent la
connexion en 5G au sein du vélo de Rome
grâce à la 5G et bien écoutez par
exemple les journalistes photographes
qui sont présents sur l'événement qui
photographie les pistards sur la piste
on va prendre l'exemple d'un journaliste
de l'agence de France Presse et bien dès
qu'il prend sa photo il peut directement
l'envoyer et mettre la photo à
disposition à l'agence grâce à la 5G
autre chose qui est possible c'est pour
les téléspectateurs qui sont dans les
tribunes et les spectateurs les
spectateurs dans les tribunes
téléspectateurs
après alors pour les spectateurs en
tribune qui sont dans le vélo de drone
et bien grâce à leur smartphone il se
connecte à la 5G ils ont accès à une
application qui s'appelle vogo et grâce
à cette application ils peuvent choisir
l'angle de vue de la course qui est en
train de se dérouler sous vos yeux cet
accueillir reçu son centième patient le
jeudi 13 octobre au Chesnay rock en
cours
objectifs ayant amené à l'ouverture de
ce service d'hôpital de jour et de
permettre une fluidification du circuit
de prise en charge du patient au sein de
la clinique
de permettre aux patients de de
concentrer ces rendez-vous de prise en
charge sur une seule journée depuis
septembre l'établissement a fait
l'acquisition d'un scanner coronaire de
dernière génération un matériel
permettant une acquisition accélérée
afin d'éviter les flous liés au
mouvement des patients lors d'un examen
il est très très bon en cardiologie
puisque en un quart de seconde on arrive
à faire une acquisition sur la totalité
des coronaires c'est un examen qui est
peu invasif
qui est qui a une valeur diagnostic très
intéressante pour pour tous les patients
de cardio effectivement l'école a voulu
changer de logo parce que c'est vraiment
une école qui s'occupe de toutes les
productions que ce soit les productions
végétales les productions animales tout
ce qui est
l'industrie agroalimentaire mais aussi
toutes les questions environnementales
du coup on a étendu notre logo aux
agricultures et puis on s'intéresse
aussi à toutes les problématiques des
filières qui veulent bien comment
travailler en bonne intelligence avec
l'environnement alors vous êtes
responsable du campus de le je rappelle
et je me rappelle que vous avez une
carrière d'enseignante avant du VSQ et
vous avez rejoint le sa alors il faut
raconter un bout de cette école qui est
assez ancienne elle a été créée je crois
à la fin du 19e siècle à Angers elle est
d'ailleurs le siège principal est
toujours à Angers tout à fait
c'est ça qui s'appelle le sa pari
tout à fait il y a combien je crois à
peu près un peu moins de 3000
d'étudiants à peu près
d'étudiants
3200 étudiants donc une cinquantaine de
formations et à peu près un tiers
d'étudiants qui suivent le diplôme
ingénieur donc ça c'est le diplôme
historique de l'école
ingénieur agronome d'études donc on
recrute les élèves post-bac en fait et
on les accompagne pendant 5 ans
d'ingénieur agronome il me disait il
m'avait dit j'ai fait ça parce qu'on m'a
dit que ça mènerait à tout et donc
effectivement ingénieur agronome vous
pouvez tout faire donc ça va de la
recherche ça va à l'innovation mais
aussi dans la production ça va dans le
conseil mais ça peut faire aussi du
marketing ça peut aller sur les marchés
internationaux de négoce etc donc c'est
vraiment un métier qui mène à tout
est-ce que est-ce qu'on peut encore
s'inscrire oui tout à fait alors c'est
notre donc on a ouvert à la rentrée en
septembre 2022 donc il nous reste encore
des places donc là faut prendre contact
avec vous contacter sur le site web et
puis ensuite surtout c'est l'année
prochaine donc voilà
et encore un petit peu il faut aller
donc c'est post-bac alors comme je vous
dis après on fait des admissions
secondaires donc l'année prochaine avec
nos premières années de cette année qui
seront deuxième année on sera ravis
d'accueillir éventuellement des gens qui
souhaitent changer d'orientation ça
c'est tout à fait possible et d'ailleurs
ça apporte une mixité qui est très
intéressante après l'effort le réconfort
un concours Top Chef était organisé avec
un jury composé notamment de chef
yvelinois les sportifs invités étaient
chargés de créer un apéro sain avec des
aliments locaux il y a un joli événement
où on fait des trucs pour les gamins et
SOS Gazelle est présent c'est les gens
qu'on voit souvent donc c'était cool de
pouvoir rendre l'appareil la journée
s'est achevée sur une vente aux enchères
maillot de match de Messi signé raquette
Roland Garros ou encore maillot de rugby
du Stade Français au total c'est 20000
euros qui ont été récoltés
il y a un maillot de Messi pour vous
moi c'est un maillot de Dan Carter si
vous me trouvez un maillot de Dan Carter
sur dans le PS dans le match que tu es
très peu de temps à vos PSG Nice
vous vous êtes marseillais donc moi je
pense que je l'aurais acheté je l'aurais
acheté quand c'est quand même Killian
Mbappé j'aurais acheté allez 1500 euros
je crois et 5400 celui de Messi
Mbappé il est en train d'écrire ça les
gens mais je pense que ça va les prix
vont s'envoler encore plus dans quelques
années je pense que c'est un bon achat
et vous serez la star la star
je pense que ça serait Pelé je pense on
va le rappeler
grand ouvrage
on va essayer pour consommer le moins
possible faut déjà avoir une attitude
zen il faut pas s'énerver ne pas se
laisser influencer par les autres
puisque la conduite économique c'est
nécessite un petit peu de gérer les
inerties et donc les espaces et parfois
il y aura besoin de laisser d'espace je
pense de l'espace notamment quand ça
roule mal puisque ça évite
comme c'est vite de subir les effets
fréquents des personnes qui sont devant
nous sur un périple parisien par exemple
et l'idée quand on met de la place par
rapport au véhicule qui sont devant nous
donc du coup c'est limite les erreurs
parce que ce qui consomme le plus c'est
de partir de zéro et de redémarrer quand
le feu au loin il est rouge ça vaut le
coup parfois de lever le pied un tout
petit peu plus tôt comme ça pendant ce
temps-là le feu passe au vert et
justement ça permet de ça permet de se
donner la chance à ne pas avoir à
s'arrêter de continuer à évoluer
justement avec un minimum d'arrêt et
pendant ce temps là en fait on consomme
0 ce temps que le temps que le régime le
temps que le régime moteur en fait
continue à descendre on consomme zéro
puisque maintenant on a tous des
véhicules avec des moteurs injection on
consomme 0 ça permet justement bah de
profiter de rien consommer d'avancer
quand même et d'espérer que le feu vert
s'allume et donc de pouvoir relancer la
voiture d'ailleurs de plus en plus de
boîtes automatiques proposent en fait un
mode roue libre ce qui permet en fait de
pouvoir lâcher l'accélérateur encore
plus tôt
alors je sais bien que les personnes des
personnes qui m'entendent vont
certainement dire oui mais quand on met
en mode roue libre le moteur tourne au
ralenti c'est vrai amateur qui tourne au
ralenti consomme de l'ordre d'environ un
demi litre à l'heure mais par rapport en
fait à l'endroit où on va lâcher
l'accélérateur notamment très tôt ça
permet souvent aussi de d'être très
bénéficiaires c'est vraiment le rêve
américain que je viens de vivre puisque
l'âge d'or a été sélectionné
officiellement à la 33e édition de ciné
Quest où il a été projeté deux fois le
film a vraiment reçu le succès que
j'attendais auprès du public l'étape des
festivals est vraiment cruciale parce
que d'une certaine manière elle peut
permettre d'ajuster aussi la promotion
du film en fonction des retours mais
aussi elle permet tout simplement
d'élargir le public du film en
discussions avec les distributeurs pour
que l'âge d'or soit diffusé Géna sur eux
rêve que son film sorte en salle au
cinéma 98 millions d'euros c'est
l'investi l'investissement du
département des Yvelines pour le futur
campus de l'innovation mine Paris la
pose de la première pierre de ce
programme de 14000 mètres carrés a eu
lieu ce matin à Versailles Satory c'est
ici que fin 2024 trois laboratoires de
pointe de l'École des Mines
s'implanterons ils accueilleront 750
personnes dont 300 chercheurs et c'est
une nouvelle étape dans le projet du
plateau de satori intégré on le rappelle
à Paris Saclay ou un nouveau quartier
est en construction et où la ligne 18
doit s'arrêter à l'horizon 2030 écoutez
ces interviews
les Yvelines c'est aujourd'hui un
territoire où la recherche est
développement ce qui fait la richesse
d'un pays c'est dans les Yvelines que il
y a le plus de pépites et ce laboratoire
c'est laboratoire c'est trois
laboratoires des mines vont venir
nourrir ses pépites et c'est pourquoi le
département a fait cet effort très très
important nous avons trois laboratoires
qui se regroupent dans des domaines qui
touchent la transition énergétique et
les matériaux pour la transition
énergétique et également tout ce qui est
robotique véhicule autonome nous sommes
effectivement au cœur de la transition
énergétique et de la transition
environnementale
il est né de l'idée d'une association
qui s'appelle science civique et
elle-même est né au moment du débat du
grand débat national c'est elle qui
avait animé enfin ce sont des membres
cette association qui est vanimer le
grand débat voisin et puis on s'est
rendu compte de l'appétence des des
habitants à discuter et à débattre donc
cette association s'est créée et donc un
de ces objets justement et ben c'est de
réunir les citoy sur différents thèmes
et de faire évoluer les villes enfin en
tout cas nous donner des idées donc ils
nous ont proposé de lancer une grande
consultation appelez voisins 2035 et ils
ont fait un travail vraiment très très
important ils ont fait des ateliers ils
ont fait des visites exploratoires ils
ont mis en place une appli avec 50 ans
en Yvelines d'ailleurs pour créer une
cartographie interactive où les gens
pouvaient se promener et mettre leurs
remarques là où là où il se promenait et
puis ça s'est terminé par un grand
sondage où il y a eu 450 réponses et
bien sûr la ville a été partenaire
puisqu'on les a accompagnés déjà d'un
point de vue financier parce qu'on leur
a permis de d'embaucher une apprentie
qui les a aidés et puis également on a
procédé avec eux un tirage au sort dans
les listes électorales donc on a tiré
900 personnes au sort pour les invités à
participer à tous ces ateliers et ses
marches ce qui n'était pas exclusif bien
sûr de tous les habitants qui avaient
envie d'y venir et donc oui vous avez
mis en place une enquête citoyenne du 15
juillet au 30 septembre vous avez fait
le compte-rendu hier soir qu'est-ce
qu'il en est ressorti de cette enquête
alors c'est l'association qui a mené ça
bien sûr donc hier soir c'était le rendu
en fait de tout le travail qu'ils ont
effectué pendant presque un an et avec
différentes thématiques ça peut être des
thématiques autour des déplacements je
crois que c'est des sujets qui nous
intéressent tous évidemment que ce soit
dans les déplacements courts
c'est-à-dire comment améliorer les
déplacements piétons et cyclables dans
la commune mais également entre les
communes et puis comment améliorer les
déplacements par exemple nous on se
projette sur cette ligne 18 qui va être
aux portes de voisins donc avec l'envie
d'avoir de créer des liens évidemment
avec cette gare il y a également tout ce
qui concerne la ville inclusive comment
comment est-ce qu'on vit ensemble et
comment on fait les choses ensemble avec
l'idée par exemple d'une résidence
intergénérationnelle pour bien puisque
on est en train d'en construire une donc
c'est plutôt
on va tous un peu dans le même sens de
toute façon et donc voilà on a parlé
rénovations énergétiques aussi parce que
les habitants sont intéressés pour leur
pour leur propre habitation
environnement voilà tous ces sujets qui
qui ont fait sont classiques mais qui
ont donné lieu à des envies à des idées
et qui vont donner lieu maintenant qu'on
a fait la restitution hier et les
habitants il y avait une centaine de
personnes ont à nouveau travaillé
ensemble et ça va donner lieu à un récit
dans le cadre du Mois de sensibilisation
octobre rose le centre médico-social du
lac de Mantes-la-Jolie organisait des
ateliers dans le but de faciliter la vie
des malades Gabriel Gontier est à
participer à une de ces séances on
regarde son reportage voilà on respire
bien
une grande inspiration
et on expire à première vue il pourrait
s'agir d'une simple séance de relaxation
mais les soins prodigués aujourd'hui par
Valérie maillot socio-esthéticienne sont
à destination des personnes atteintes du
cancer ou en rémission afin de les
accompagner au mieux l'associo
esthétique c'est prodiguer des soins de
bien-être de confort à toute personne en
fait fragilisée par la maladie notamment
ici le cancer mais aussi par la
vieillesse
le handicap alors les séances sont plus
ou moins le même profil c'est des
séances qui durent environ une heure
c'est un mélange d'écoute et de soins
dans le but comme vous l'avez vu dans le
reportage de relâcher les zones de
tension la particularité de ces soins
c'est que la socio-esthéticienne elle
s'adapte complètement aux demandes et
aux besoins des patients on sait que les
traitements contre le cancer notamment
contre le cancer du sont parfois
douloureux donc tout ça c'est des choses
qui sont pris en compte pour les soins
et puis ça dépend aussi des envies de
chacun ce que beaucoup de bénéficiaires
nous ont dit en tout cas c'est que ces
séances sont très importantes pour eux
parmi tous les rendez-vous médicaux
qu'on imagine à l'hôpital ça fait partie
des rendez-vous qui les attendent avec
impatience et vous l'expliquez dans le
sujet c'est très important ces séances
sont prises en charge oui tout à fait
c'est ce que j'expliquais dans le
reportage dans le nord des Yvelines où
nous avons réalisé ce reportage
justement les malades ont le droit à 5
séances prises en charge par an alors
cette prise en charge elle se fait grâce
à l'association de la Ligue contre le
cancer des Yvelines et le dispositif
d'appui à la coordination c'est ce qu'on
appelle le DAC ici c'est le DAC Nord et
ce que nous expliquait les patients
c'est que c'est une véritable charge en
moins pour eux parmi tous les frais
qu'ils ont déjà
à prendre en charge de leurs poches en
ce qui concerne le reste du département
il faut se rapprocher de la date Sud
pour les questions de prise en charge
vous allez de présenter une créatrice
yvesinoise et je crois que vous nous
avez concocté un petit jeu mais
effectivement un petit jeu autour de
cette créatrice qui s'appelle Mélissa
sebir et elle est à Richebourg elle a sa
boutique elle a ouvert sa boutique en
mars 2022 à Richebourg et je vous
propose un jeu c'était en fait cette
créatrice a particularité c'est qu'elle
est éco-responsable et récupère du
matériel du tissu pour le transformer en
vêtements et donc on va on va on va bien
l'écouter elle a des questions pour vous
on va écouter d'abord la première
question d'après vous qu'est-ce que j'ai
pu coudre dans ce couvre-lit d'après
vous voilà alors un couvre-lit un
couvre-lit vert à votre avis elle a fait
quoi avec ça
des rideaux une nappe
une robe avec on va écouter la réponse
et regardez bien
la réponse c'est cette robe trench que
vous pouvez porter pas uniquement à la
maison mais dehors aussi je vous assure
voilà
deuxième on va on va faire la deuxième
question on va voir le deuxième matériel
proposé
deuxième tissu donc c'était un rideau il
reste plus grand chose justement deviner
ce que j'ai fait avec ce rideau
voilà un rideau rose à votre avis elle a
fait quoi avec ce rideau rose moi je
sais peut-être Gabriel une chemise
peut-être
une écharpe
Gabriel c'est ça allez réponse
la réponse est ce chemisier vintage
en or voilà le petit chemisier avec des
boutons en or c'est très beau en tout
cas allez dernière allez dernière
question vous pouvez vous rattraper
Grégory a un point Gabriel a un point
Mathilde c'est à votre tour de on va
écouter la question à votre avis à
partir de ce rideau qu'est-ce que j'ai
pu coudre
une jupe une jupe
c'est une jupe que vous allez d'ailleurs
pouvoir découvrir dans le reportage
installer à Richebourg près de Houdan
Mélissa ouvert son magasin en mars 2022
l'artisane a commencé son activité en
2018 elle était encore salarié mais
libinoise qui de son emploi en mars 2020
pour se consacrer pleinement à son
activité entrepreneuriale trouver que la
mode
l'artisanat en fait dans la mode était
en train de complètement disparaître on
en entend plus parler au profit
justement de ces gros industriels qui
produisent en surproduction dans les
usines donc plus d'originalité beaucoup
de problèmes aussi de taille mal coupée
vêtements qui tourne au lavage bref la
qualité qui commence à devenir un petit
peu compliqué chemisier manteau jupe et
vêtements sont divers la créatrice vient
même de lancer une collection pour bébé
à la mode de Mélissa
alors j'ai regardé les chiffres c'est
quand même assez dramatique puisque on
dit que la fréquentation du cinéma est
la plus basse depuis 40 ans c'est ça
c'est ça exactement alors souvent on dit
voilà il y a deux grands facteurs les
gens ont perdu avec le covid l'habitude
d'aller au cinéma c'est une première
chose et le deuxième facteur c'est
l'arrivée des plateformes qui fait que
bon chez soi et on a on a pratiquement
ce qu'on pourrait avoir quand on va au
cinéma est-ce que c'est votre votre
analyse est-ce que c'est la seule année
alors moi je reprendrai les deux
facteurs que vous venez dénoncer je suis
absolument d'accord effectivement les
plateformes ne nous ont pas fait du bien
du tout surtout que il faut rapprocher
ça je pense du problème peut-être aussi
du prix des places qui est quand même
devenu relativement élevé
une famille de quatre personnes
sujet bien comprise c'est à peu près 9
10 euros par mois
est-ce que c'est pas un petit peu trop
cher je certains militent pour ce soir
encore un petit peu plus cher en allant
vers le Premium etc moi c'est pas mon
avis mais bon les avis sont partagés je
pense aussi que les plateformes pour
pour en dire de mots très rapidement
draine aussi tous les scénaristes c'est
à dire qu'il y a on monte on manque de
scénariste dans le cinéma et ça se voit
ça se sent là je regarde un petit peu ce
qui sort l'année prochaine les trois
mousquetaires vous voyez encore une
version de trois mousquetaires alors
j'espère qu'elle est réussie il y a
Vincent Cassel voilà on en a quand même
vu un certain nombre déjà donc il y a ça
je pense aussi qu'il y a un problème
d'offre de film c'est à dire que oui je
crois que au-delà de ce changement
d'habitude d'ailleurs j'ai regardé moi
aussi enfin c'est le monde a fait un
gros papier là-dessus j'ai regardé les
chiffres Roomba la vie le film de Dubosc
a fait 200000 ans pas terrible il y a un
film canaille avec José Garcia François
Cluzet qui est absolument
de 60 000 entrées je crois enfin bon une
catastrophe catastrophe une jeunesse
pour le château de Dampierre les
nouvelles façades du monument ont été
révélées au public en juillet dernier
remplacement des briques de la toiture
nouvel enduit et bois de charpente
renouvelées là la seule coup et bien les
couleurs de Dampierre reviennent l'ocre
la brique tout ça resplendit et tout ça
c'était refait admirablement par tous
les compagnons le propriétaire Monsieur
Mullier et même n'en revient pas
je vais répéter ces mots qu'il y a en
fait mon château est joli il y avait pas
imaginé que ce château était si joli
parce que quand il avait acheté
évidemment il était dégradé près de 300
personnes on devrait depuis 2020 à
l'embellissement du château un des plus
gros chantiers privés sur un monument
historique ouvert au public en France
les ouvriers peaufinent actuellement les
derniers détails sur la base des murs
vient de nous rejoindre en plateau
bonsoir bonsoir alors on l'a vu dans le
sujet vous êtes le directeur général du
domaine de Dampierre en Yvelines alors
première question déjà qu'est-ce que ça
fait de voir un peu les premiers
résultats après deux ans de travaux
ces deux ans de travaux ont permis de
mener de grands un grand manifeste en
tout cas sur ce chantier et c'était
vraiment la grosse surprise quand on a
fait tomber la bâche qui protégeait
cette ce chantier la seule coup on a vu
ses couleurs apparaître qu'on avait
oublié parce que parce que le château
était précédemment dégradé et qu'il
s'était affadis et que pendant le
chantier on avait mis une énorme bâche
qui reprenait le dessin du 17e siècle et
on avait dans la tête encore le dessin
du 17e et là on a redécouvert ce château
restauré et ça a été vraiment comme dit
d'ailleurs le propriétaire
c'est émouvant et c'est joli c'est joli
parce qu'en fait le château évidemment
il est très très prenant il est énorme
enfin il est lourd de passer et en terme
de culture c'est aussi très important et
là en fait et bien on voit aussi
l'aspect esthétique et l'aspect
esthétique ça fait plaisir à voir et
d'ailleurs l'aspect esthétique et ça
veut dire que si on a enlevé les
bassines dans le château donc du coup
j'ai reçu quelque part une réjouissance
quel bilan vous faites depuis votre
arrivée au château de Dampierre elle a
un bilan très enthous reste parce que je
rappelle quand je quand l'équipe elle
s'est mise en place quand je suis arrivé
d'Empire avait été effacé
des circuits touristiques alors on va on
n'a pas remis en place avec les bus et
autres parce que pour l'instant c'est
les travaux mais en tout cas il y a un
public qui répond ce que j'avais
présager et à tel point c'est qu'on a
commencé la première année avec 20000
visiteurs et en trois ans on est arrivé
à 45000 l'année dernière en visiteur
donc ça veut dire que on a vraiment un
public qui est en attente et qu'on offre
si possible des animations qui
permettent au public de découvrir sous
différentes différents regards en tout
cas ce patrimoine on a fait les plaisirs
de Dampierre avec les costumes qui
évoquent la vis de Louis XVIIIe siècle
mais par exemple on fait aussi les
balles de Dampierre l'art de l'attelage
l'art de Hippo Hippo et automobile on le
commet en avant on essaie de à chaque
fois de trouver des points de de
développement et le public répond et je
vois d'ailleurs la reprise à ce point
c'est que vous aussi vous vous êtes
fidèle vous m'invitez à nouveau quatre
ans après et d'autres médias et bien
font aussi appel à nous en disant mais
voilà vous commencez à vous développer
et donc voilà il y a une belle une belle
synergie qui est mise en place et avec
les partenaires aussi locaux et
territoriaux importants évidemment le
conseil régional qui nous aide le
Conseil départemental également enfin
vraiment tout le monde nous aide à
vraiment créer cette dynamique suivie
alors on va passer 3,5 à 3,8 c'est le
chiffre du jour exactement Patrice c'est
le nombre de personnes travaillant à
temps plein au sein du service de
pédiatrie de l'hôpital de Poissy
Saint-Germain-en-Laye en temps normal
ils doivent être 15 médecins et donc à
cause du manque de personnel depuis
vendredi dernier les parents qui se
présentent avec leur enfant ne sont plus
accueillis le service ne prend que les
hospitalisations et les enfants adressés
par le SAMU la situation devrait durer
jusqu'au 7 novembre qu'il s'agissait en
fait d'une expérimentation technologique
de surveillance du futur site olympique
qui va accueillir les épreuves de
cyclisme sur piste en 2024 un ballon
captif à 120 mètres d'altitude qui
embarque plusieurs outils technologiques
de surveillance ce dispositif est
actuellement testé et pourrait être
utilisé durant les Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques de Paris en 2024 on écoute
à ce propos le préfet Olivier de
Mazières délégué au partenariat aux
stratégies et aux innovations de
sécurité on a 170 expérimentations de ce
type qu'on est en train de conduire pour
le compte du ministère de l'Intérieur en
relation étroite avec les industriels et
notamment le comité stratégique de
filière des industries de la sécurité
une fois que ces produits auront été
expérimentés comme aujourd'hui qu'on
aura décidé qu'ils sont efficaces et
qu'on les aura acquis ils seront
évidemment à la disposition et sous
l'utilisation pleine et entière des
forces de sécurité donc c'est le métier
il y a l'entreprise c'est Nimr space qui
a développé le ballon mais ensuite il y
a des d'autres entreprises qui
collaborent à ce à ce système notamment
sur les technologies et notamment
l'entreprise ou le groupe s'affront
électronique scène defend c'est le
motoriste aéronautique a développé
notamment ce système euroflure 410 un
équipement électronique avec plusieurs
dispositifs de détection longue portée
donc vous voyez vous l'avez vu peut-être
à l'image il est fixé sous le ballon
captif et permet d'assurer une
observation assez large et pour en
parler nous sommes avec Anne que Anne
Caroline leming donc il est responsable
grand compte chez Safran électronique
ndefense et du coup est-ce que vous
pouvez nous expliquer en quoi consiste
ce système tout à fait donc eurofir
c'est un système de haute technologie
française comprenant plusieurs caméras
permettant de voir deux jours comme de
nuit et dans toutes les conditions
météorologiques grâce notamment à
l'infrarouge et la beauté du système et
qu'il est extrêmement bien stabilisé en
fait tous les porteurs aéroportés que ce
soit des aérostats donc des ballons
comme des avions ou des hélicoptères
sont soumis à des vibrations et à des
mouvements d'air et donc pour conserver
une image qui soit nette et qui soit de
haute définition les systèmes comme le
refaire 410 doivent bénéficier d'un très
haut niveau de stabilisation ce qui fait
partie des savoir-faire de safran la
France a briller lors de ces Mondiaux de
PA sur piste 2022 à domicile dans ce
blodon national de 50 ans en Yvelines et
tricolore emporté 17 médailles pendant
les quatre jours de compétition les
Bleus terminent 3e au tableau des
médailles en termes de performance
sportive les athlètes ont bien répondu
présent et on a de nombreuses médailles
après la deuxième satisfaction c'est
qu'il y avait trois quatre jeunes
dont on attendait pas ce parcours sur
ces championnats et qui ont prouvé que
2028 c'était pour eux un peu trop loin
et qu'il voulait avancer un peu plus
vite que prévu côté bleu la star de ces
championnats du monde restera Alexandre
léotté ce jeune français de 22 ans
termine ses mondiaux avec un bilan de 4
médailles d'or une médaille d'argent et
des records du monde ce dimanche le
pista remporte notamment l’omnium et le
15 km scratch j'avais beaucoup bossé
j'ai
amélioré beaucoup de choses dans mon
quotidien aussi pour que ça fonctionne
le mieux possible et je vois que ça
fonctionne et que le fait de souffrir à
l'entraînement ça paye donc je suis très
content une sportive locale c'est
également distingué Christelle
ribothermine 3ème du scratch 10 km en
catégorie C2 comment ça s'est passé pour
pour cette équipe de France plutôt bien
17 médailles un bon bilan
on peut pas on peut difficilement faire
mieux je pense que en effet 17 médailles
là c'est c'est quand même énorme moi
j'ai surtout souvenir d'avoir participé
au championnats du monde de parasite de
Para cyclisme en 2018 et je crois qu'on
était 6 ou 7 athlète seulement à s'être
déplacé moi j'étais pilote de Raphaël
avec l'équipe de France moi j'étais
pilote de Rafael baujillais qui a fait
médaille de bronze
tandem
à l'époque et c'est vrai qu'on était
désolé
on était 6 7 6 6 7 à tête grand maximum
c'était vraiment pas énorme et
aujourd'hui on voit que les moyens qui
ont été mis en place pour Paris 2024
aussi bien sur para cyclisme que sur
d'autres sports en règle générale et
bien portent leur porte leur fruit c'est
vrai que la moisson qui était déjà très
florissante à Tokyo pour le pour le
paracyclisme
fait que ça continue la synergie est
positive c'est vrai que c'est quand même
formidable de sortir 2021 avec autant de
autant et c'est plus facile de sortir
avec une belle moisson que quand c'est
difficile donc là ben voilà c'est si je
pense une continuité il y a pas de
surprise mais c'est plutôt une
continuité quand on arrive sur une
compétition nationale ou internationale
vous avez un bilan à faire devant un
médecin un médecin du sport qui va vous
mettre dans une catégorie dans une autre
donc en effet vous avez les moins
handicapés donc les handicaps invisibles
comme Marie patouillé peut l'être ou
encore que
qui est la versaillesse et qui a
remporté deux argent
donc Marie patouillé elle elle a une
malformation au niveau du pied donc
quand on la voit au quotidien on le voit
pas tout à fait
et donc elle est en catégorie C5 et
ensuite plus vous avez un chiffre qui se
rapproche de 0 au nombre de C1 et même
plus vous êtes handicapé et là et là
quand on voit
quand on est sportif quand on a une
carrière valide et que l'on voit
certains chronos dans des catégories C2
ou C1 ce sont des vrais leçons de vie
encore plus admiratifs
je me souviens d'un russe à la en étant
un même hôtel qui ne pouvait pas manger
tout seul et quand il était sur le vélo
bah il faisait des chronos que je
n'avais jamais été capable de réaliser
sur le premier départ c'était un qui
n'avait pas de membre supérieur sur le
départ sur le premier tour c'était
vraiment difficile mais une fois que la
machine était envoyée oh là là c'était
impressionnant à voir et puis après vous
avez d'autres d'autres je me souviens
d'un Espagnol un bras en moins une jambe
en moins et vous dites le mec il est sur
un vélo et il prend du plaisir et il
s'amuse et ils ont toujours le sourire
et ça rigole et et ça rigole et ça et ça
va même entre des supers moments et moi
c'est j'ai fait une saison avec avec
Raphaël bougilais et j'en garde une un
très très bon souvenir
[Musique]
alors je vous propose de découvrir
l'oeuvre d'un jeune peintre qui
s'appelle Arnaud Adami et qui explose à
l'espace Richou à Versailles jusqu'au 20
novembre prochain
on s'interroge souvent sur ce que c'est
l'art contemporain certains peut-être
visiter je sais pas ce week-end Paris
plus par Basel ou Asian now à Paris il y
a plusieurs formes de Dark contemporain
et fut même un temps où on s'est
interrogé sur la pertinence de la
peinture ce qu'il fallait pas trouver
d'autres supports pour pour faire de la
contemporain bien si on s'interroge là
dessus il faut aller voir les œuvres
d'Arnaud Adami qui vont fournir une
réponse parce que leur contemporain ça
consiste simplement à rendre compte de
la société telle qu'elle est avec avec
des peintures c'est très intéressant
alors il peint c'est pas des livreurs de
délivrero des des gens qui ramassent les
des éboueurs qui ramasse les poubelles
des avec des instruments voilà comme
comment on les voit ici sous de Dieu
des choses de la vie de tous les jours
et je trouve que c'est absolument
formidable ce qui fait parce que il y a
des voilà des gens qui se sont
invisibles dans la vie dans la vie
quotidienne et grâce à grâce à ses
peintures c'est pas dur hyper réaliste
on redécouvre autrement tous ces métiers
d'abord il y a des couleurs absolument
formidables et je trouve que c'est un
travail artistique absolument
passionnant c'est la fin de ce best of
du 7 8 demain on change de moi pour voir
ce qu'il s'est passé en novembre dernier
bonne fête sur TV 78
[Musique]